hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
with season 1 of fortnight chapter 2
running for so long it can be easy to
forget what has happened so I thought it
was a good idea to sum up the complete
story of what night chapter 2 in 10
minutes this will include the end of
season X so the end of chapter 1 and how
that impacts the new island or when if
you're wondering why this video is so
short it's simple I want this one to
follow on from the last story video I
did in Chapter 1 so if you want to watch
all the live events in order and how
they all link together I will link that
now but right now we are delving into
chapter 2 so sit back for 10 minutes
use code Adam are you in the shop to
keep these weekly videos coming and
let's figure out everything chapter 2
has to offer if you're ready cue the
dramatic music this story begins back on
the old fort night island when we were
stuck in a time loop back in September
2017 we forgot about the husks outside
our homes and began to battle one
another in online training programs
endlessly fighting one another for that
victory royale
we did this for so long that we forgot
why we were fighting in the first place
the original Battle Royale Island was
created for a single purpose to train
the last remaining human beings to fight
the undead the fiend the husks which
wiped out 98% of the human race we have
evidence that this is a training
simulator as we never actually die
we are digitally deconstructed and then
sent back to the lobby to do it all over
again well what if I told you we were
stuck inside a program we've been here
for so long we've even forgotten how to
speak all right people let's search this
dump and get out of here ASAP suddenly a
primitive recording was found which gave
us the answers we needed the first
visitor told us about the infinite loop
we find ourselves within and most
importantly how to break that cycle when
you hear this again or once loops will I
be just as muted as the others and why
not you I find myself looped activate
the beacon at precisely the moment this
timer reaches nothing the zero point
must be contained once more if they are
correct it will be the end every season
an event would take place always
attempting to destroy something in loot
lake time went by and only in the final
season did we see the truth the only way
to stop this loop in time was to destroy
the nexus point what the seven of us are
attempting is very risky they are not
the only ones watching but it must be
done or we lose the bridge forever no
matter it seems my lengthy precautions
worked in the real world
this was the mainframe computer running
these training drills it came down to a
mysterious group named the seven who
tried seven times to destroy the orb and
finally thanks to the scientist they
succeeded
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the mainframe was switched off but we
didn't awake in the real world we stayed
in limbo a black hole of nothingness
were the seven wrong is this really the
end of fortnight after a lifetime of
waiting something miraculous happened
the Nexus restarted the mainframe
computer rebooted and attempted to load
us back into the battle royale training
program something though had changed the
world looked familiar but also brand new
something in the code had been
duplicated copied or deleted
we had combined our reality with another
version of events resulting in our
original Island named Athena by the way
imploding and the new Island popped up
called Apollo Apollo amongst other
things is a god of prophecy and Oracle's
telling us that chapter 2 is full of
questions we need to answer but where do
we find them the seven sent forward a
team named ego to find answers before
our arrival the ego elite team searched
the island constructing safe houses
everywhere but they couldn't find the
answers every time they came close they
were confronted by another unit the
altars
[Music]
the altars looks like clones of the ego
squad but how would that be possible
something is going on here and this is
where the story of chapter 2 becomes
extremely interesting egos emblem is the
key to what's going on by rotating the
logo around we finally see why we are
here
a bunker over the next few weeks the ego
Squad attempted to find the secret
bunker around Apollo Island but Apollo
was ready for this
it had a secret protocol which copied
and duplicated combatants ready to
defend the vault at all costs they will
try and keep this [ __ ] the battle raged
on for more than 15 weeks and now a new
anomaly has occurred the computer
program and our reality are combining
the ego squad and the alters have
inadvertently birthed a third unit the
red and blue combining to create purple
the loving nature of remedy counteracted
with the torture focused toxin the
innocence of Ripley versus the blind
rage of sludge the island is learning
and evolving during this war facing off
each member to create a new combatant
perfectly placed between the good and
evil the light and dark war and survival
then without warning the fusion was
complete a new entity created by the
bloodshed on Apollo Island complete with
an energy source which could be another
zero point as we approach the live event
we are left with questions what is
inside that bunker why are the two
realities fusing together and who is
behind it all are the seven still
watching us or is this another power at
work our only choice now is to defeat
alter and find the answers ourselves
[Music]
well what do you think about that theory
could we be lost inside a computer
simulation is it really a zombie filled
world outside so many questions to
understand and so many more answers to
find like what is really inside that
bunker could there be a home base here
will we find dr. Vindi Minh or will this
be another husk invasion or maybe maybe
it's something worse I don't know the
answers but I can't wait to find out I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]